have you ever thought about standing for
your local body elections it's a great
way to serve the community and to have a
say in the future of this district we
need new candidates for our community
boards council and miR and almost anyone
can stand you don't need any special
qualifications but like any job there
are certain qualities that can help you
become a more successful candidate
these include being noan or connected
within your community having good
leadership or decision-making skills and
knowing the issues that are important
locally so make a difference nomination
I rope and now grab the forum or find
out more at Waimakariri
not govt tnz food slash vote 2019
[Music]